also breaking right now union rally just
started on the strip members are
demanding resorts higher back
hospitality workers that were laid off
during the pandemic oracle mana joining
us now live from the strip with those at
the rally and what kind of turnout
they're having orca
well denise and brian hundreds of
hospitality workers are here out on the
las vegas strip right now actually
blocking part of the boulevard in front
of planet hollywood and the paris area
this is the we will come back stronger
rally hosted by the culinary union you
can see casino workers as well as other
unions and community allies out here all
fighting to protect hospitality workers
and get them their jobs back you'll
remember when cobia 19 shut down the
strip casino and hospitality workers
were largely out of work the culinary
union says 35 of their members are still
not back to work right now and it's been
about 20 months since the coveted
pandemic began that's about 21 000
people the union says they want the las
vegas gaming and tourism industry to be
successful and that includes all
hospitality workers to be able to fully
return to work again hundreds of casino
workers taking to the las vegas trip
tonight to make it clear those who are
still without jobs are ready and willing
to get back to work now the rally just
started minutes ago at five o'clock and
it's scheduled to continue for a little
while so we of course will stay out here
and bring you any updates to this rally
as it continues for now reporting live
on the las vegas strip tonight pork
omana live local now